how about you guys Tanya and Robert what
do you prefer I know there is always
like a big discussion do you prefer the
bishop pair the knights the bishop and
the Knight what do you prefer you take
it first I'm a bishop person I have to
say I love the Bishops but of course it
depends on the position when you've got
a bishop there you're really looking for
an open position so that your Bishops
can be on these diagonals these are
long-range pieces they need space to
breathe and to really Thrive and
flourish but in this position as we can
see the Bishops are behind their own
pawns and there really isn't that much
to play for also Knights are super
tricky so be careful of them and I would
say In classical games I love myself a
bishop bear but if it was bullet Blitz
give me a night I need aha